Louie Gohmert represents the great state
of Texas in the United States Congress
though tonight he was in effect accused
of representing st. Petersburg and
Moscow he joins us tonight to clarify
congressman thanks so much for coming on
you were denounced as a tool of Russia
tonight tell us how that played out well
it's such an outrage because the thing I
was pointing out is that if you want to
really look at the facts look at in 2008
Russia invaded Georgia and Bush reacted
adversely and he put sanctions in place
and then in March of 2009 Obama sent
Clinton happily for Clinton over with a
red plastic reset button and the message
to Putin was clear Bush overreacted when
you invaded Georgia with all those
sanctions we don't overreact when you
invade and so you know to Putin it was a
green light go ahead and invade Crimea
but of course Putin was smart enough he
waited until Obama won a second term
because he had more flexibility to allow
Russia to do things but they have been
the pawns of the Russians they they you
think you think the current president
Trump would ever allow our uranium to be
sold to Russia
exactly the irony